bonjour donc je suis Sam j'ai 48 ans je
suis ingénieur je suis le papa de
Souhail el Khalfaoui 19 ans tué par un
policier stagiaire à Marcelle à
Marseille en 2021 lors d'un banal contre
le routier mon fils a été abattu à bout
portant d'une balle en plein cœur
quelques secondes après qu'il ait
demandé à sa maman à au fonctionnaire
pardon à appeler sa maman
je voudrais comprendre pourquoi mon fils
est mort alors qu'aucun des policiers
était en danger au monde du tir
je voudrais comprendre pourquoi les
policiers ont laissé mon fils agoniser
pendant plusieurs minutes sans lui
porter secours
j'aimerais aussi comprendre pourquoi le
meurtrier n'a pas été placé en garde à
vue
j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi les
policiers ont menti avec la bénédiction
de l'IGPN sans pour autant être déféré
par le procureur
j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi l'IGPN
comme par hasard a perdu les images de
vidéosurveillance d'une banque qui était
située à moins de 10 mètres du crime
aujourd'hui il y a une plainte il y a un
dossier le parquet avec la session 8
l'affaire en mois de décembre a été
rouvert en match du Cambier quand on a
montré les irrégularités
aujourd'hui il y a trois plaintes
une plante contre policiers
de plein contre l'IGPN
pas de plainte contre les policiers qui
ont menti lors de la déposition parce
qu'il faut savoir en France un policier
a le droit de mentir en enquête
préliminaire il ne risque rien pas de
sanction administrative pas de sanction
pénale
ce que je dis j'ai la preuve quand
j'étais au menti c'est une preuve le
parquet à la preuve l'IGPN a la preuve
c'est une preuve de témoin avec vidéo à
l'appui
monsieur le ministre en 2022 il y a 12
autres familles qui ont perdu un enfant
tué par la police
des suites d'un refus de tempéré et
l'année n'est pas terminée
combien faudra-t-il de plus pour
considérer que c'est une
question
internationale de se dire qu'il faut
faire en sorte de
d'abroger cette loi de 2017 qui n'est
rien d'autre qu'un
plat réhabilitation du permis de tuer de
façon arbitraire
évidemment c'est déjà
témoignage poignant parce qu'on sent sur
toutes les motion et ceux qui nous
regardent la sainte émotion
ce ministre la question de Sam elle est
claire aussi enfin il y en a plusieurs
mais déjà la première question c'est
pourquoi son fils est mort
on l'a dit pour la petite Lola c'est ce
qu'il y a de pire au monde quel que soit
les circonstances il y a une enquête
judiciaire vous l'avez dit Monsieur
c'est encore pire quand il écrit par la
police
je pense que c'est pire tout ça c'est
perdu mais c'est vrai que c'est voilà on
comprendrais aussi que vous l'avez dit
vous-même il y a une enquête judiciaire
donc on connaît pas moi c'est votre
vérité je la respecte on laissera les
magistrats évidemment on l'a dit vous
avez dit vous-même d'ailleurs que le
parquet a réouvert quand vous les avez
interpellé ce qui montre en France on
protège pas particulièrement les
policiers le parquet ouvre il y a
aujourd'hui une enquête judiciaire je
peux juste répondre à ça ils ont ouvert
en janvier ils ont on est au mois
d'octobre ils ont pas conclu en fait
c'est mon ma plainte directement
ils ont pas ils ont rien changé donc
c'est juste c'est juste vous avez raison
mais que ce soit le parquet que ce soit
le juge vous avez aujourd'hui une
enquête
qui est confié à des services il y a des
magistrats qui vont donner leur réponse
si j'ose dire à ce qui s'est passé ce
sera la bonne réponse et moi je vous
dire ici monsieur que si les policiers
ont voté évidemment ils doivent être
sanctionnés et comme n'importe quelle
personne qu'il faute moi je passe
d'ailleurs beaucoup de temps à prendre
des sanctions contre des personnes qui
sont dans mon administration après vous
avez raison monsieur il y a des gens qui
meurent parce que la police attire
il y a aussi beaucoup de policiers qui
meurent parce que les gens ne s'arrêtent
pas et vous l'avez dit oui mais ça
refuse d'obtempérer moi la première
chose que je peux vous dire Monsieur
c'est que quand un policier gendarme dit
de s'arrêter je pense qu'il vaut mieux
s'arrêter c'est je pense qu'on parlez de
bon sens tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est un bon sens je crois que dans
l'affaire qui concerne la mort très très
touchante comme vous l'expliquez de
votre fils il y a un policier qui a été
blessé également alors sur mon fils je
pense je voudrais juste spécifié quand
même il était à l'arrêt il a fait une
marche arrière un policier d'après le
rapport médical à des blessures à léguer
je pense que ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que la politique était blessé
je pense qu'on peut aussi dire que votre
fils voilà était connu tes services de
police
non mais c'est vrai et je pense que vous
n'avez pas ça
il a été condamné pour être rentré dans
son collège et avoir passé le bras pour
écarter une viande pour récupérer une
casquette
il a été arrêté
de cannabis monsieur vous savez vous et
moi nous savons que c'est pas tout à
fait c'est quoi la vérité moi je suis
pas là Monsieur monsieur monsieur
il y a une troisième condamnation mon
fils je vais la vérité
mon fils était papa
parce que du coup c'est un orphelin son
fils orphelin aujourd'hui
il a mis une claque à sa femme
à sa concubine après la naissance du
petit voilà les condamnations de mon
fils et ce qu'il y a avec la police les
éléments que vous avez monsieur le
ministre moi je suis pas là pour parler
de la vie d'avant de ce que il y a
d'autres éléments moi je suis encore une
fois il y en a pas d'autres c'est parce
qu'il y a ce qui est porté à ma
connaissance mais voilà mais vous aurez
voilà de toute façon quoi qu'il arrive
votre fils malheureusement voici
malheureusement est mort et c'est tout à
fait normal qui est une enquête et c'est
tout à fait normal que si des policiers
ont utilisé leur arme de façon non
réglementaire qu'il soit sanctionné mais
avouez vous parlez que la police
tu vous reprenez les mots du monsieur
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure vous savez que
moi le premier chose que j'ai faite
quand je suis devenu intérieur c'est
d'aller voir la famille de Mélanie Lemay
c'est une gendarme de 26 ans qui a eu la
jambe arrachée sur une route
départementale dans Lot-et-Garonne et
qui est morte dans son sang à 26 ans
parce que c'est pas arrêté et vous savez
j'ai dit qu'il y a une vingtaine de
policiers de gendarmes que j'ai enterré
plus de la moitié c'était pour des refus
d'obtempérer des gamins de 22 ans aussi
des policiers adjoints ils sont fait
chauffer parce que de voiture une moto
s'arrête pas donc je pense monsieur
qu'on peut tous se dire que la violence
faut qu'elle s'arrête juste
si j'aurais juste terminé si vous me
permettez si je mise à l'intérieur que
je suis ne vous rappelle pas aussi qu'il
y a 3400 plus de 3400 policiers
gendarmes blessés depuis le 1er janvier
de cette année là encore il y a un
gendarme contre la vie et la mort vous
l'avez vu en Gironde parce que quelqu'un
ne s'est pas arrêté je serai pas non
plus amusé à l'intérieur digne donc je
pense que devant votre émotion je peux
vous dire profondément que s'il y a des
gens qui ne sont pas conformes à l'idée
je le fais de la République et qu'ils
ont des tâches de sang sur leur uniforme
en fonction je ne je ne je mais
évidemment j'ai 600 sanctionné on aura
l'occasion d'en parler pour d'autres
sujets mais on va laisser la justice sur
son travail je comprends tout à fait
votre deuil et je crois aussi qu'il faut
dire qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
tuent les policiers et les gendarmes en
s'arrêtant pas